how's it going rose I just want to let
you know before we start this episode
you can watch the entire rest of this
series that's like five hours of alien
or something up now on p2p net I will
link it in the description so you can
check it out I'll also link it by the
end of this episode so while you're done
watching this you can go there and check
the rest of this series I hope you bros
appreciate it and enjoy how's it going
res man it's beautiful got a new
microphone today gonna figure out if
that [ __ ] [ __ ] before the cops lockdown
what are the codes to bring it in on
auto don't do that not happening Marlowe
that right well you know where I am
wait my board in the text bytes
Plan B set it up whatever's happening I
want in okay this way got something here
you'll know what's going on here
this place is kill anyway I'm gonna go
collect the flamethrower I like the
sound of that I like this how that
Marshall can I collect it please where
do I collect it apparently in here Wow
let's hope this thing works right it's
an animal animals are afraid of fire I
hope you're right
we go killed acting we gon kill acting
go kill that [ __ ] about what
happened what happened what just
happened ah microphone is still working
all signs are okay alright oh Jesus
well thank you there's gonna be fun baby
girl it's gonna be reappoint
singing am i singing back station
alright where are we I want to get about
as soon as well can I have a bad eye so
please
well you can't have anything alive can
again you flamethrower only flamethrower
they can't quite reach it for some
reason
well I didn't want you anyway all right
you guys yeah you better be scared
you've been as scared of this Pathan I
stuck this Patong step further up the
South Pole if you know what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying alright let's
kill it kill it with fire which way
though further down all right you boys
ready for this
I can't wait to flame up this [ __ ] yeah
I've sent your guys Samuels to Android
processing once these things dead I'm
gonna get him back says Apollo and lift
the lockdown
Samuels okay doing that guy said he
wanted to help and I have my hands full
here besides he's a synthetic should be
easier for him to get in there
I knew it was a sign Patek standing
between Sebastopol an outright disaster
all right disaster has already happened
weights all we can do now is kill that
[ __ ] let it burn let it burn gonna
make that [ __ ] burn let it burn
let it burn gonna flame that [ __ ] to
hell I don't care if it's ethical or not
better son come on
so far the microphone isn't [ __ ] me
over you piece of [ __ ] I mean I can do
this tastes like chocolate hello I
should say here they're all canceled
Steve Urkel what are you doing here you
schmuck son of a [ __ ] I feel badass for
the first time in the game I mean the
game gives us badass is stuff like a
stone baton and you just like wood but
then you realize you're just a little
[ __ ] it's kind of like real life I
would say but there we go we got one way
ticket to head can't wait to actually
kill [ __ ] oh god what could it be
oh [ __ ] we should probably just lease
blazed through
the creatures here oh let's go that's
like Universal 4 well [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
going home all right how are we gonna
seal it in
sounds amazing how the [ __ ] did we get
there
Jose feeling very paranoid at the moment
ah this is it something bad happened
here diffing real bad safe station
goddamn asleep station you what are you
doing here thought I told you to go home
oh god it's here it's here
alrights one of those I just wanted to
make a burger that's all I ever wanted
oh oh that's [ __ ] oh thank you I'll
be going then go into the SERP don't
[ __ ] with me don't [ __ ] with me right
now you're [ __ ] with the wrong person
right now a guitar I'll take that
oh Jesus Christ calm down a guitar it
was this a joke
alright I got you I got you hombre oh
[ __ ]
don't make me fry your ways
up or down I guess we go down then you
look pretty hot well aren't we all
oh I'm supposed to go in here that's why
I couldn't do it
Jesus I'm an idiot
why what is this well that's good bloody
well - no Jason Christ man getting tired
of their windows all right let's be
careful subasta link well I don't know
the passcode 7 7 8 9 well leg no it
means no
go away no one likes you save station
yeah my safe station ciao oh you look
like The Crooked Man skills me talking
through the Crooked Man
don't what the hell happened here at
Lisa's servers yeah it is sure as hell
looks like it we have one more area just
well this is awkward
Oh Shh Jeremy you're gonna kick my oh
babe oh I'm backin up backin up backin
up backin up cause my daddy let me
search peoples that are dead
I'm backin the hell out of there and I'm
like oh my god well I need those let's
make some med kits there we go
okay let's go into my toe for good old
times sake but oh I'm gonna go in you
all the side is it out there I don't see
oh god oh god yeah it is
[ __ ] that why go that way when you can
avoid a bottle it's in here isn't it yep
oh hi
lock down the server farm they said
spray his ass with fire they said
what do I do how about a noisemaker no
that's
it's too risky maybe he'll go away in a
while
damnit I don't see I'm on the map though
that's weird
Oh oh great he's hungry for love that's
the best all of us oh oh did he see us
I hope not where the hell did we lock
this down the server's from here Oh in
here server control of course yes
distract him with boring science they're
like best buddies alright can we do it
this is gonna be tricky
come on come on come on fine Oh God not
this one
Oh God Oh God uh don't forget yes yes
I hate those I'm so bad at timing
what it's in here no get out of my house
Oh God
let me loot you
how do we turn this [ __ ] off it should
be here somewhere one of the computers I
bet no you are my darling I don't know
if I trust you though Oh God this is
really quick nice and easy
uh-huh hurry hurry hurry high load is it
curry
Oh God Oh God
shut up Ricardo is my exit clean oh he
doesn't sound too happy I'm happy
Oh
how great so but you ratted me out
didn't yet hi I got me Christ the Christ
is not the proper reaction to that [ __ ]
I don't have more time how the [ __ ] did
he find me no he doesn't even care ah
Oh save station got a lab my same
station oh oh he's not coming is he okay
we don't have a lot of time I make all
the way huh
this will be fine no you ugly ho
oh thanks ah gosh where should I go you
take the elevator to jail and iLabs if
it follows we can still drop it there
come on that was all for nothing
Jesus
[ __ ] me man where's the [ __ ] elevator
this is not an elevator but according to
the map it is
whoa potato man that was close
whoo oh my god
Jesus hi are you insane or some [ __ ]
this is face look friend a [ __ ]
look I Bey look I um you might want to
run there's this giant alien that eats
your face that has a crush on me so you
want it my way Nate might want to get
the [ __ ] out of here Terminal Island for
the synthetic caretaker in sinister God
oh good timing great timing
can anything be done quietly in this
game and it's like every time someone
tells you to do it quietly okay enough
talk now wait now shut the [ __ ] up
wait this fix it it's really cool I
don't know what a days it'll looks cool
dad damn it he had a point
I couldn't yeah I could whack in wow
what a great security this is the future
has uh-huh
innovation no [ __ ] that all right our
work is done last my torch well about
time baby girl about time hey nice face
I loved what you did with the place oh
god don't come now how does this work
did it did a beta beta babe later
aligator subasta link what do we get
bring with the kids any interesting
interesting got it
I don't need scrap Jesus [ __ ] you scare
me man
[ __ ] you [ __ ] alright now we can use
his computer ha ha ha
stupid [ __ ] he's gonna be so pissed
when I found all his porn yeah
where can I find the power breakers
weights I see one in the analysis labs
yeah I guess what that means really is
like hey let's do it let's make pills do
all the [ __ ] he's been doing the [ __ ] so
far really good so why not make him do
some more [ __ ] well that wasn't really
my my intention when I was in what's in
here I'm curious about this I can climb
in there what the hell why would I have
a climb in here this sucks
hello no it's actually kind of cosy I'll
call this place my own home I would just
hide here with my flamethrower with this
entire time but that's just that's what
I do with my life if there was a [ __ ]
alien that has a crush on me
can't they distract it or something for
me like do something useful with their
goddamn life I don't think this is where
I'm supposed to go it's just like
another type of vent looks cool though I
appreciate it
hey almost by my face up okay let's go
to the depot that's definitely the right
direction
bring it on sister oh is that what I
think it is Shan Shan Shan god I love my
sha sha Shan thank you thank you
hey sister go sister may I get that soul
sister
yeah no matter I mean the flower and
everything that's my that's my rapping
you like it I know you do
thank you stop it break and research
required oh why didn't you tell me come
on man ah ah ah help
he got my leg ugly ugly how do you think
you going what a [ __ ]
who says [ __ ] like that how do you even
come up with that [ __ ] right computer I
am alright what are we doing in here the
power that must be a generator somewhere
won't see it though
ah hey Bri yeah
we have to go up up up bap bap to the
tub Oh God is coming it's coming go up
up up up up up up oh damn oh god oh god
oh god oh god bring it bring it bring it
oh how [ __ ] wonderful ah burn this
[ __ ] chair you scared my - off I
don't have an ass anymore look how much
I'm wasted on you you better not come
back and stab me now I'm gonna be pasted
illegal what illegal sex now a like a
see kitten
- seven four three two seven four three
two seven four three two seven four
three two seven four three two seven
four three two seven four three two
seven four three two seven four three
two seven four three two seven four two
three two seven four hurry up please
[ __ ] me oh god Jack I clicked the wrong
[ __ ] bar dad why does it have to eat
my face out of all places there's the
least amount of meat here you want to go
for my ass about you know aliens ml you
know my ass is lump chutes and filled
with fat you love it
so where did the [ __ ] are we supposed to
go then here okay got it all right we
made it this far bros oh no no it ain't
fair sir that's so unlucky are you
serious are you milking me right now
go down go down go down go down yes we
save station please save station yeah
must have station yeah okay we all have
one more thing to do that is to not die
can we do it yes we can
all you're working now now aren't you
piece of [ __ ] I don't know if I dare to
talk to you so much don't link oh well
I'll make an exception
oh [ __ ]
what ah what's up got stopped oh it's
happening now come on
King he didn't ah oh man Sam had a lamb
and he said hit it BAE in a baby in a
bed am but I am Putin tintin tintin
tintin no no thank you
no no [ __ ] thank you appreciate it
though but no thanks I went great
348 let me know when you're there I
can't wait to go there
where's the [ __ ] lift no no
tired of you so tired what the [ __ ] does
this nightmare ever end
oh god I'm getting pissed and that's a
good kind of pity they're not the kind
of pissed would you just pee all over
yourself and be like oh that's pretty
nice I think that would be that bad not
that kind of pissed don't touch me I'm
[ __ ] fabulous okay no see I know you
what you want to do Oh Oh God you got my
legs
you got my legs no I don't want to kiss
you
let's take the vendor out it's the
cozier out the route that I prefer
because I'm lonely and no one loves me
that's my favorite kind of route lonely
forty pies normally no one likes him not
even his subs ah I think that's how it
goes
Wow we made the amazing progress of
going from that side to this side Wow
I'm sure we won't die now it seems to me
that we have to go all the way around
there but I think there's a way there F
[ __ ] it if you are oh you can yell no I
think that's what a great man once said
that was me spoilers big spoilers to
everyone believe you all right let's
just go down these ugly ass stairs
that's right I stairs I dis you what you
gonna do though [ __ ] nice face what
what you did with it
oh we can walk through here interesting
there's one get goes here I think I'll
I'll take I'll go with this one please
they got too fat for this one [ __ ]
is it here no how can you keep finding
me how god I need to restore power why
does every godforsaken place not have
power I can't see [ __ ]
but it smells like beeps ass I love it
alright we're almost there wait did I
miss it
oh here's the elevator with that aide uh
oh yeah we did it high-five
that's amazing amazing that is amazing I
love it just love it
alright brace go to end that if it's
over there if you enjoyed hit that like
hey hit that like button if you enjoyed
it thank you for watching birds stay
awesome la beep aha
alright so you watched through the whole
thing huh well you might as well spend
another four hours well as promised you
can check out the rest of this series
over at Peapod net link is in the
description I see you bros there